Hey,
what's going on is bill burn is time for the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
January 21st,
2019 what's going on?
How's it going everybody?
How was your weekend of playoff football?
I'll tell you right now,
if you didn't have a fucking view,
didn't have a fucking dog in that fight,
you just sat back and enjoyed both of those fucking crazy games.
Um,
sort of I guess.
yeah,
I don't even know where to begin.
All I can just say his overall,
both of those games is exactly what the NFL wants,
which is heart attack,
fucking football games.
And I know there was a lot of shit given to the refs,
but I think so much of it is them just applying 20 years of rule changes that
all essentially benefit the offense.
MMM.
It drives me fucking nuts.
I know.
I always sound like an old man,
but I hate it.
I fucking,
I can't stand it.
I know my team won,
but I fight those fucking games sucked yesterday.
Okay.
I just,
I can't fight him.
I don't know.
I don't even know where to begin.
I mean,
if that's what the fuck you want to watch,
just two teams just going up and down the field.
Can you believe in it's 56th 52 oh my God.
Now they scored 59 56 if you want to fucking watch that for a God damn three
hours.
You know what I mean?
You'll,
you'll like some fucking fat kid who wants to go right to dessert,
you know,
no one wants to eat their vegetables.
No one wants to see any fucking difference.
MMM.
I don't even know where to begin.
I actually somehow sat through the Patriots game just sitting there,
you know,
I got my daughter now,
so it's like I'm not going to be this guy flipping out and everything like that.
And I was able to remain calm.
MMM.
Until 39 seconds left in the game.
And after that I just lost my shit where I was just like,
this is so fucking,
I was already watching like the chiefs now,
you know what?
The first time I lost my shit was when it was,
there was nine 54 to go in the game.
We had fourth any yard or a half of the yard.
And we had essentially for the NFL,
a chip shot field goal,
which would've put us up by six.
Okay.
And I'm thinking,
and,
and we go for it and we don't get it and we're fucking kills me was no one gave
Bella check any shit because that's just the way the game's played now.
It's like you'd be up by six,
even if the chiefs go down the field score a touchdown,
they're only going to be up by one and now you can go down the field,
kick a field goal,
go up by two or score a touchdown and put it away for the fucking life of me.
I don't understand the way the game is played now.
And I guess,
cause I'm sitting there,
well,
I'm just a stand up fucking comedian.
He's bill Bellacheck.
Obviously he knows what's what you're supposed to do here.
I think there's just so many rules that are in favor of the offense that you
just know the other teams essentially going to score.
We can't,
that,
that taking a three points is like,
uh,
like not,
um,
I dunno.
It's like not kicking an extra point.
Who gives a fuck?
I have no idea.
I don't fucking get it.
Um,
I haven't said that.
I know there's a bunch of people upset about the officiating and you know,
I mean,
I,
I'm,
I'm with you on it.
I don't think all of them were bad calls.
I just think there's just a bunch of bad rules that totally tipped it in the
favor of the offense.
If you just look in the last year,
Tom Brady threw 500 yards in a Superbowl in lost
Patrick.
My homes is a rookie quarterback and he threw 50 fucking touchdowns.
I'm not saying the guy isn't great.
He's fucking unbelievable.
I love him.
Okay.
But 50 touchdowns by a rookie,
this something wrong with the eleague.
MMM.
Last week we tackled Philip Rivers while he had the ball and we got caught for,
we got called for roughing the passer this week.
I watched the chiefs,
the guy's hand,
I think it caused air that that disrupted Tom Brady's eyelash,
not even eyelashes,
his eyelash.
And they got called for roughing the fucking passer.
Then Patrick,
my homes actually got hit,
which was also a fucking love tap,
a love tap and he's wearing a helmet and I saw him look at the ref and while I
was watching the game I was like,
all right rock,
you're going to get that call in two to three years.
You don't have the seniority yet to get that call.
But Tom Brady gets that call.
But that's always get the calls.
All right,
but that's fucking shit.
Whereas a,
an offensive lineman is pushing you down and you're only thing is you can dive
at the quarterbacks of legs and you actually sack them and then they call you
for roughing the passer.
I mean,
I don't know what to fucking do with that.
MMM.
I Dunno.
But you know,
if chiefs fans are going to whine about the ref,
the officiating,
you know or whine about that non call on your fucking pick play too.
I mean,
let's be fair about it.
Um,
I also,
as a patriots fan,
I was surprised that they reversed the call on Adelman touching it because on
the replay it looks like he doesn't touch it.
But you can't say that it didn't touch his forearm hair.
Um,
I guess they went with the ball,
didn't change sort of direction,
wobble stopper or anything like that.
I was surprised they switched that.
But um,
all you fucking wine paiche Patriot haters out there who say the referees love
us guy.
You're really forgetting deflate gate.
Roger Goodell fucking hates us.
The league does not like us.
Okay.
They allowed the owner of another team to conduct his own private investigation.
This wasn't the league.
It was the owner who poo paid a guy to dig up dirt and the dirty found he also
found with the colts,
they completely ignored all of that.
Suspended our quarterback,
the golden boy.
Ooh.
Don't touch him.
Suspended him initially more than they suspended a guy on the ravens who fucking
knocked his wife out on video in a fucking elevator.
So I don't know what world you're living in.
I think it just sick of fucking lose into us and I will go with that.
The officiating was terrible.
I'll go with the,
at the fucking rules are terrible,
but I don't,
I stopped short of that.
The refs love the Patriots.
MMM.
Yeah.
Roger Goodell fucking hates us.
Okay.
And he did everything he could fucking do to suspend our quarterback,
which he ended up doing.
He actually lost it in a court of law and then like the little fucking cunt that
he is,
he went back and completely switched his argument.
Not that the Patriots are cheating,
was that that they were a corporation.
Tom Brady's and employee doesn't,
a corporation had the right to suspend an employee and the court was like,
yeah,
fine.
He's our employee.
He suspended.
All right.
So if that's loving us,
I don't know what to tell you.
MMM.
Having said that,
my heart goes out to fucking chiefs fans.
I was actually,
you know,
at one point being like,
all right,
if the chiefs,
when this,
then I can just fucking relax during a fucking super bowl.
I can watch old NFL,
classic old NFL team.
The rams verse,
a classic old AFL team,
um,
in the chiefs and,
and I could just fucking enjoy a god damn Superbowl for once without having to
fucking sit there,
you know,
having a fucking heart attack while the whole world's watching,
wanting your fucking team to lose and then have to listen to comments for you.
You're like nick foals kick Tom Brady's ass when he threw for almost half as
many fucking yards.
It's like no,
he beat the Patriots defense.
Okay.
The only guy,
I wouldn't say he beat Tom Brady was fucking uh,
Eli Manning.
Cause Eli manning is the only guy in a game.
I think Tom Brady could questionably say he fucked up when he threw to Welker.
He through the back shoulder welcome.
Probably should've caught it.
Who the fuck knows?
I'll give you that one.
But other than that,
every fucking Superbowl Tom has drove the team down the fucking field for the
winning touchdown.
It's our defense that fucks it up.
Like yesterday.
Yeah,
39 fucking seconds left.
And what these fucking rule changes.
Okay.
Or up by three points,
you kick it away.
You're them on the 20 day driving all the way fucked up dude,
too.
Fucking offensive plays in there on our 20 yard line.
Okay.
If there was 49 seconds left,
they would have had a chance to throw it into the fucking end zone.
Like that was when I was up off the couch when it went into overtime.
At that point,
I didn't even give a fuck who won the game.
I was just like,
fuck this.
This isn't even fucking football anymore.
It's a fucking joke.
It's just,
it's just Madden Instagram.
Every fucking game out is,
they changed the rules to the point where it's going to turn into the,
the,
the 40 or the Miami Dolphins,
San Diego charges,
which was,
uh,
a game of the decade happens like every three weeks now.
Now I know I sound like a fucking curmudgeon here,
but like,
I dunno,
I miss,
I miss great defenses with nicknames and Shit.
I guess the last one maybe was Seattle with legion of boom,
but I don't even think that took off.
I think that that was just in Seattle where everybody used to say doomsday,
purple people eaters,
steel curtain,
the sack exchange,
all of that shit.
Um,
I dunno.
Let me ask you this guys.
W W W who's the fucking Ronnie Lott in the League right now?
Who's the Jack Lambert?
Where's the fucking Ray Lewis?
They just,
they don't fucking exist.
They're not allowed to play the fucking game.
If you can tackle a quarterback with the fucking ball and that's roughing the
passer,
man,
I don't know what the fuck to tell you.
Um,
and furthermore,
people will keep saying that Tom Brady's the greatest of all time.
It's still Joe Montana to me,
Joe Montana,
one four in one decade with two different coaches heal his bill.
Bellacheck quit and you are allowed to beat the fuck out of the quarterback.
So if Joe Montana plays today,
Bill Walsh sticks around like they'll Bella check does and he doesn't take that
hit against the giants and he plays into his forties.
I think you can get five.
All right.
I know in this first 10 minutes you wouldn't know that my team won.
But like,
you know,
I don't know,
I just
don't listen to me.
I'm just an old fucking man who's watched the game change and I'm acting like,
who was that guy that played for
the eagles?
He was the last guy to start both ways.
And there was an NFL film clip of him,
cause he used to always shit on the new games,
the new players because they didn't start both ways.
And you'd be like,
oh,
I wouldn't watch a football game every day of your baby.
Anyways,
so that's my take.
I don't think the referees love the Patriots.
I just think that it's
okay.
It's just all about the offenses.
Now having said that,
talking about the saints and the fucking Rams,
the saints absolutely got royally fucked over s times too
by the referees because it wasn't like that play was away from the ball.
It was where the ball was going and there was two major,
major fucking penalties on that play that have literally changed game to the
point you have a rookie quarterback throwing for 50 fucking touchdowns that was
pass interference and helmet to helmet contact.
The whole fucking stadium was looking where the ball went.
Yeah.
You know
that Kansas City pick play that no Kansas City fan is going to fucking bring up
when they whine about the officiating.
I,
I can see them missing that play.
You know,
you're watching the fucking ball,
this,
you know,
four or five players all fucking moving at the same time.
But that was,
I don't know,
I don't get that.
And people who argue that the saints could've put the rams away,
you're acting as though the rams aren't the rams who it's looking like they have
the next bill Belicheck on their hands as a head coach who's only like fucking
33,
34 years old now it's going to take 60 minutes to put them away.
Um,
I usually like that argument that,
you know,
you've,
uh,
you know,
you got to put a team away when you have a chance to put a team away.
Um,
I wouldn't use that with the saints because the rams or to go to fucking team to
be like,
well,
we handled them and a half,
let's just fucking play our game and show up the clock and,
you know,
and we can just win this one going away.
Um,
I would have used that argument against the Patriots where we should have kicked
that fucking field though.
I just don't understand.
I don't understand going forward.
Were up by three fucking points and you're going forward,
like there's no time left on the fucking clock and you're down by four.
Uh,
but that's,
you know,
I guess that's how the fucking games plates.
So here we go.
Another Superbowl.
Um,
the chiefs are the team of the future though,
in the AFC,
even if I'm,
believe it or not,
this is a rebuilding year for the Patriots,
having lost all the talents of free agent that we have.
So the fact that they made it to another fucking Superbowl is ridiculous.
Um,
okay.
But like I said,
I don't know.
I'm sure this is coming off like what the fuck?
But like I don't,
I don't sit there and talk shit and rub other fucking people.
You know,
like I played that noses in it.
All I can say is like NFL football has changed the way stand up comedy has
changed in the last couple of years to the point like you don't even fucking
recognize it.
You know,
I'm sitting here watching other comedians going on radio shows and,
and,
and social media attacking other fucking comedians and literally saying what
they should or shouldn't be saying on stage is like,
what the fuck am I watching?
And I watch NFL football.
You know,
you can't hit a quarterback below the knees.
You can't hit him in the head.
He can have the ball and you,
if you tackle them too hard or in one of those areas,
it's roughing the fucking passer.
If you push them down onto the ground,
Dude.
How many fucking times?
By the way,
we'll a quarterback throw his shit fucking ball and the defensive back goes up
to intercepted and the in the y and you know at that point the defensive back
has position and the wide receivers behind him on his back hands all fucking
over him.
It breaks up the fucking pass.
Not only is it not interference,
the guys in the booth guy was a heads up play.
Um,
okay.
That's why you have everybody's thrown for 5,000 yards and 50 fucking touchdowns
is all I'm fucking saying,
which is why you can't go back and look at Joe Montana and say that he is
somehow inferior to Tom Brady.
I just don't buy it.
All right,
so here we go again.
Now I'm going to age and other 10,000 fucking years and fuck all you guys are.
Go You fucking spoiled Patriots Fan.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Okay.
Walk a mile in my fucking shoes.
I've been in your shoes where you never fucking get there.
That's sucks.
Losing an AFC championship game sucks.
I'll tell you what's worse.
Losing a fucking Superbowl when the whole world's watching.
So the next time you go to Belgium,
some asshole shows up with the fucking,
you ain't no giants or an eagle shirt and get you,
you get worldwide shit for that loss.
Um,
so anyways,
I'm just an old curmudgeon who would like to see more of a balanced game,
but I also think because of that CT shit,
they kind of have to protect everybody.
So I do love seeing defensive players hitting with their shoulders and not
hitting guys in the head.
I do like that aspect of the fucking game.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
I don't know.
Other than that,
I don't know what the,
I don't even know what the fuck I watched yesterday and I have been consistent
with that the whole fucking year.
Yeah.
All right.
I hated that chiefs rams game.
Um,
and as much as you guys are gonna just sit there saying I'm some whining
patriots fan.
I,
there was literally NFL players tweeting.
What the fuck I was saying,
Teddy Bruschi,
Richard Sherman,
they all said the same thing I did.
And you fucking cunts.
Don't bring that up to you though.
Yeah.
Um,
all right.
Uh,
Um,
okay.
You know what it is.
It's also because now I have a kid and I can't get out all this fucking energy.
Okay.
Like I just sit there stoically and then it just fucking builds up.
So I'm sorry,
I'm regurgitating all of this shit.
Um,
having said that,
congratulations to the ramps,
you know,
you're not making the calls out there.
My condolences to the saint fans.
That was my pick.
Um,
I did not like the Patriots chances against the saints.
I don't really like them against the Ramsey.
That'd be honest with you.
Um,
I definitely think the NFC stronger and Micah Donald to chief fans.
all I can say is that you're going to,
I,
you're definitely the team in the future,
in the AFC.
Um,
yeah.
Unless,
I dunno.
Brady keeps fucking drinking his fan prior,
prior blood and plays until he's 45,
but even then,
the homes is so fucking young.
Um,
okay.
I Dunno.
Anyways.
Yes.
Uh,
this weekend,
uh,
celebrated my daughter's second birthday.
I made a fucking birthday cake like a champ.
Um,
sorry,
dude,
I'm fucked.
I'm sorry.
I'm fucking spent from both of those games.
Just today I had those games and my daughter's birthday.
So the whole first part of the day was stressing out.
That might,
no one was going to like my birthday cake running around making sure,
you know,
the,
the bubble lady was showing up who've,
who crushed it by the way.
We had a guy come by,
did the music portion,
everybody loved that and we built it perfectly.
And then there was the bubble lady and then we did the birthday cake.
It was perfect opener.
Middler headliner,
you know,
the whole thing worked out.
And um,
the kids freaked out.
The bubble lady was like,
next level,
like kids love fucking bubbles.
So all you have is that little fucking won,
you know,
that you,
your blow the bubbles through.
And then this lady came down with like fucking four kiddie pools with these
bubbles.
The size of like special effects of,
of summertime,
blockbuster.
And these kids who were like,
I is this,
is this really happening?
Like they didn't care about it.
They didn't even care about cake.
After that she shut down the birthday cake with the bubble display that she put
on,
you know,
other parents where they're going.
Where did you find this person?
They were getting her information.
She was crushing it,
you know,
it was like watching a comedian do a private gig and there's like three other
companies there and he gets,
he gets like three,
four more fucking gigs out of it.
Um,
I dunno,
I don't,
I feel like I went to fucking hard on the officiating in the fucking game does
going on,
but I,
I just,
I dunno,
maybe I'm just worn out watching the fucking games.
But
um,
anyways,
plowing ahead here.
Um,
yeah,
so we knocked all of that out and then I watched them.
My daughter takes her nap and I watched that first,
the first game and then she woke up,
we did more birthday stuff.
Then I watched the Patriots game on tape delay announced the next morning.
I'm like,
just fucking worn out here.
Um,
I can't fucking believe they're in another Superbowl.
I can't fucking believe it.
Unfucking real.
Does Brady have plinth fifth?
They win this.
Do you think Brady retires?
The guy should retire.
Right.
Okay.
Then he goes,
what does he have?
He's got,
yeah,
you'd have six.
He would be tied
with the Steelers who for some reason are considered the New York Yankees of NFL
football.
Um,
you know,
I've never really gotten anybody to fucking explain to me why they don't count
NFL titles because the packers are the team.
And then at then I think it's like the giants because the giants have won four
super bowls.
Yeah.
And I don't know how many NFL titles they've won.
Let me check this shit out.
I love this nerd shit here.
Um,
all right.
New York giants,
your New York giants.
All right.
What are they got here?
Alright.
Easter's written marriages,
blah,
blah.
Okay.
Don't even tell me then.
Nfl Championships,
pre 1970,
they have four.
So the way I see it,
okay.
I,
you know,
I should make a list of these things.
The fucking New York giants have eight titles.
Okay.
For Nfl titles and four Superbowls.
So they should be ahead of the Patriots
because we have
five Superbowls.
That's it.
Okay.
Um,
I wouldn't count AFL titles
the same way you're in a,
you don't count Aba Championships.
The Aba merged with the NBA and the Celtics still got to keep all their
championships in the Minneapolis.
Lakers got to keep those a fucking Lakers even kept a BA championship that they
send out counters an NBA championship.
I'll never not bring that up.
Okay.
All right.
You know Stanley cups go all the way back to early.
He fucking 19 hundreds and world series.
They give the fucking Philadelphia Phillies,
let me look them up.
They get credit.
They want one in fucking 1880.
You know they want to one in like 18 fucking 80,
where like if you brought it up like hey,
how come in 1880 if you brought up like,
hey,
how come there's no black people on your team?
First of all they'd say,
what's a black person?
And then refer to say,
you mean Edwards?
You mean former slaves?
Like that's how long ago it was.
Okay,
where are we?
What happened?
How many do they want?
Let's see.
That
major title world series.
Oh wait,
1980 they haven't won one went back down.
Wait a second.
How can only say,
okay,
I put it on the Phillies.
Who the fuck was it?
First World
Series
Baseball.
Oh,
I always thought when they want it in 1980 they had one in a hundred fucking
years.
Oh,
the 1903 world series was the first modern world series.
Okay.
Is that the first one that they count?
Oh wait a second.
Wait a second.
Okay.
1884 world series.
Yeah.
All right.
And baseball.
The 1884 world series was a post season championship between the Providence
Grays of the National League and the New York Metropolitan's of the American
associations at the Polo grounds in New York City,
which is now it's in Harlem.
There's a little plaque up there.
I looked at it one time by myself because I'm weird.
While the 1884 post season championship series was the first such to be referred
to as the World Series Major League Baseball considers 1903 world series the
first.
I've been saying that for years.
Shitting on the Phillies and no one's ever corrected me.
At least I didn't see it.
All right,
so 1903 let's see,
the 1903 world series.
All right.
1903 world series
was the Boston Americans first,
the Pittsburgh pirates in the Boston Americans one five to three whatever.
Fuck five games to three,
so as best five out of nine.
Okay.
Well,
whatever it happened to the Boston Americans
say,
this is the shit here.
This is why.
Okay.
Being a sports fan is great and then also just this is what I'm going to lose.
My Boston Americans
Wiki PDF,
the Boston Americans,
Boston Red Sox are an American professional baseball team based in Boston,
Massachusetts.
Wait a minute.
The Red sox compete at the major league baseball
weighted.
That's not our first world series title is it?
It is.
That's us.
Two three four,
five,
six,
seven eight nine
we would call the Boston Americans
well series,
but blah,
blah,
blah.
I didn't,
I had no idea.
I didn't know that.
1903 now.
Who the fuck played in that game?
Okay.
If the Boston Red Sox can count a 1903
yeah.
I mean,
we didn't like their way.
There was no option to fly to a game.
No one had ever flown before.
19 Oh fucking three.
Yeah.
Ladies,
gentlemen,
how about a round of applause for all our heroes from the Spanish American war?
Jay coming down and I let me try something.
Shea,
that was still fucking 20 years away.
Yeah,
they didn't even have motion pictures.
Jesus Christ,
they're fucking Masco is probably a fucking Doto burgers.
Probably still alive back then.
Named the only fucking major league baseball team with an endangered species
that was at the fucking ballpark when it won his first world series.
All right.
Now if they can count that shit,
why do I care?
Why do I care this much?
All right.
Stanley Cup
j a list of Stanley Cup champions.
How far back do they go?
Um,
1890 fucking three the Montreal hockey club.
Now you can't tell me that they played in an arena,
in an arena that that'd be like on the fucking pond.
1893 h a c champions,
comma no challengers.
Montreal Hockey Club,
the Montreal Victoria's to Macho.
Let's look for the first,
like Montreal Canadians are a team that I recognize the Winnipeg Victoria,
so they moved out to Winnipeg.
Then whether they moved to Phoenix after that.
Montreal hockey club.
This is 1903 Ottawa.
Otto was senators.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
10 fucking years in a row.
Yeah.
In 1903 the Ottawa hockey club beat the rat porridge.
This'll
all right.
I have,
I think I have to get a rat porridge.
Fucking hockey jersey.
The Kanora thistles they originally known as the Rad Porridge.
This those.
All right.
I gotta look this up.
You can't tell me Mitchell and ness has not put out a fucking rad porridge.
This'll yet.
Jersey Rad Porridge.
This'll jersey images.
Oh,
we have a jersey.
Hmm.
I Dunno.
You can buy it and there's no rat on it.
It's got the fissile on it.
Ah,
you fucking cunt.
Somebody wife came up with that fucking name.
Ken Norton.
Thistles.
Third string goalie.
19 oh seventh this'll Tommy,
Tommy Phillips Jersey.
Okay.
What would you look at that
Jesus Christ.
Look at the team photo of the fucking Rad Porridge.
This'll all right now I'm going to say the guy in the front row on the left was
the one who came up with that logo if not the other in the left and the second
row.
And those two guys might may have been dating each other.
That's what I'm getting out of that photo.
Not to say that there's anything wrong with it.
Okay.
Progressive lifestyles have existed for a long time.
They just haven't been recognized.
Um,
anyways.
Okay.
Plowing ahead here.
Um,
I'll tell you what,
I'll make a promise you,
this is the last time,
I don't know if I could do that.
I would say it's the last time that I'm going to complain about fucking
all of these fucking sports.
Jesus Christ.
He can you guys at least get,
get me that.
I'm making at least a little bit of a decent point.
You know,
how many times are you going to watch a guy drive the lane in the NBA now and
the defender literally get out of the way?
Cause he doesn't want to end up on fucking Instagram.
I mean,
that just didn't happen back in the fucking day.
All right,
let me read some,
uh,
okay.
Advertising here.
All right.
Oh look who's here.
Rolled Zip.
Uh,
you know what's not smart?
Pick one of the following.
Feel free to make it your own.
A job boards that send you candidates that aren't qualified for the role you
posted.
Okay.
But you know,
it is smart.
That's the only one that gave me going to zip recruiter.com/burner to hire the
right person.
Unlike other job sites,
zip.
Yeah.
Finds qualified candidates for you.
Uh,
for some reason they capitalize for fines,
candidate call it finds qualified candidates for you.
Uh,
it's powerful.
Matching technology scans thousands of resumes to identify people with the right
skills,
education and experience and actively invites them to apply to your job.
So you get quality candidates fast.
Yeah,
it's like Tinder for employees.
Uh,
that's why Ziprecruiter is rated number one by employers in the u s this rating
comes from hiring sites on trust pilot with over 1000 reviews.
And right now my listeners can try zip.
Yeah.
Okay.
For free at this exclusive website address,
ziprecruiter.com/burr um,
if you love this show,
show your support to it and Ziprecruiter by going to ziprecruiter.com/bar uh,
that's ziprecruiter.com/bar high zip.
Okay.
The smartest way to hire.
All right.
Simply safe.
Okay.
All right.
Simply safe.
So here's a timely stat for you.
Almost half of us make a new year's resolution.
Every single gear we've all made them and most of us are probably broken him.
Um,
I kind of have,
but my whole,
I'm not arguing with my wife has been working great.
Oh Man,
I got to have her on the fucking podcast and talk.
Maybe this Thursday we're going to talk about me buying a,
I was looking for a birthday candle for my daughter's cake.
All right.
I'm just going to,
I'm going to tease the story and I went there.
Yeah.
You know,
I just wanted the number two,
I'm making a chocolate cake.
I'm thinking something silver,
you know,
something like,
looking like that.
Right.
And I show up in all the,
all the numbers were all like this tie dye,
rainbow color.
Okay.
And I had a paranoid meltdown and refuse to buy one and I bought the silver
candles anyways,
and I'll,
I'll have Nia,
c'mon,
and grill me as to why I did that.
Um,
okay.
Oh,
it's just trying to have an agenda.
Free birthday cake for two year old.
That's all I wanted.
All right.
Happens to,
happens to the best of us.
Where am I have to the best of us,
but one resolution worth sticking to this year,
keeping your home and family safe.
That's why I recommend simply safe home security.
Simply safe is 24,
seven home security with no contracts or catches.
They believe the safest place on earth should be your own home.
So you feel protected every time you shut your door and leave for work or shut
your eyes.
Uh,
at night.
More than 3 million people already feel this way every day,
thanks to simply safe.
And they're not the only ones.
The folks at PC mag named simply safe,
both editor's choice and reader's choice for 2018 2019 feels like a good year to
ask yourself,
is my home is safe as it could be.
And if you're thinking,
well,
maybe this is the year to change that,
get simply safe,
go.
Just go to simply say bird.com to get started.
That's simply safe bird.com to protect your home and family today.
Simply safe burr.com and it's spelled s I m P L I,
safe.com.
Okay.
Um,
alright.
Plowing.
Plowing ahead.
Oh,
Billy,
booze face.
Oh,
Billy boost face also has not been drinking.
Maybe that's why I'm being such a fucking cunt about the new NFL,
you know,
ruin it.
Ruining it for younger people.
This isn't at football.
I thought what I was watching was football.
Your old bald con.
Um,
I'm going to get a lot of shit.
I don't give a fuck though.
Um,
yeah,
some fucking assholes send me some.
Are you not entertained?
It's like,
no,
I'm not.
I like fucking,
I like all aspects of football,
not just scoring,
um,
fat girlfriend.
Okay.
I actually think that they're doing it for fantasy football numbers.
I think that that's another reason why they're doing CTE mixed with fantasy
fucking football and all of that shit.
You know,
so people can keep up with this stupid goddamn like,
I hate that guy,
but he's on my fantasy team.
All right.
You know what?
I'm right.
I'm not backing down from what the fuck I said.
What the fuck you're watching is not God the m football.
It's,
it's,
it's the God damn fucking ice.
Capades all right there.
I said it and all you douchebags who play fantasy fucking football.
You can go and go fuck yourselves to there.
I took,
I took a stand.
I'm trying,
I'm tired of trying to be fucking like diplomatic on this,
but I understand the game change.
I understand these concussions.
Go Fuck Yourself.
A rookie should not be thrown for 50 fucking touchdowns playing NFL football.
All right?
You don't believe me?
Go Ass.
Fucking ray Lewis.
What he thinks about that.
Alright.
Fat Girlfriend.
Hey belt.
I'm a girl listener.
Writing in with advice for a guy with the fat girlfriend.
Yes.
Okay.
We had a,
we had a,
a a male listener.
All right.
Okay.
I don't know if he had a man bun.
I don't know if he had a flat top.
I don't know how progressive he was.
I Dunno if he was an ally.
I don't know if he likes to new fucking rules in NFL football.
I don't know if he wants to see more scoring.
I don't know if he's an old fucking grizzled.
Can't like me.
I don't know what this guy is,
but he has a girlfriend that was a little fucking,
you know,
had some pounds on.
He's like,
all right,
you know,
whatever.
We'll get a relationship.
Maybe I'll get out of her out there on the treadmill.
But no,
she kept eating cupcakes and she's getting to the point that she's,
she's a fucking house,
so he still loves her and he wants to a PR.
How do you tell somebody okay,
that there
they're not attractive to you because they've eaten so much as a man,
as a woman.
I know you can fucking do that.
Okay.
You can say that to a guy because nobody gives a fuck about a man or his goddamn
failings despite how much these broads fucking bitch about how difficult their
lives are.
Um,
you know,
and everybody's all brave.
Now if they're a woman and they're fucking out of shape,
when reality is,
is you're killing yourself,
it's not good for you.
It's not healthy and you're not brave.
You're being a fucking moron who's in denial.
I'm not saying you should fucking hate yourself,
but to just pat,
hey,
I'm doing heroin.
Look at my abs.
Hey,
I'm eating donuts every fucking day.
I've almost closed three out of four of my fucking arteries or whatever you call
them.
Is that what you call him?
And things that go on,
come out of your heart.
The fucking the intake outtake hose from the radiator.
Okay?
Yeah.
You're not brave.
You're,
you're fucking in denial.
All right?
And when somebody calls tells you that you need to drop some weight there,
they helping you prolong your life.
All right?
You can't make someone care about their weight.
That's what this woman says.
Cause I asked for a woman to come in.
She said,
I wish I had better news for him,
but if his girlfriend doesn't want to lose weight and it sounds like she
doesn't,
then she won't.
If it's a deal breaker,
he needs to break up with her and if it's not,
then he has to get over it.
Oh my God,
I,
I've,
you know something.
If you were here right now and I had your permission in writing in,
in triple kit,
I would give you a hug.
All right?
One of those hugs we have fucking lean in.
So only the tops of your shoulders touch the tops them and you do like a fucking
even your side of your heads.
Don't touch a post me to hug.
I would give you,
okay.
That mindset right there,
that mindset right there is what makes you great.
That that right there is everything you need to be successful in life.
All right?
It fucking [inaudible] was just,
that was a,
that was perfect.
Let me read that again.
I wish I had better news for him,
but if his girlfriend doesn't want to lose weight and it sounds like she
doesn't,
she won't.
In other words,
you can't make somebody,
you know,
get their shit together.
They have to want to get their shit together.
Okay.
So now that we've solved that,
that,
that it's not on you to make somebody care about themselves.
All right?
Now you have to deal with the situation.
So this is what it is.
Okay.
And if you can handle it,
get over it.
If you can't break up with them.
But other than that,
shut the fuck up about it.
That's it.
And I actually think I actually feel for this guy because if he loves her,
he's key.
He's going to watch her take 10 15 years off her fucking life.
Um,
and he hasn't even knocked her up yet because that's the other thing,
like with women,
you've got to give women a pass on at least 20 fucking pounds,
25 pounds.
You have to,
because they have kids,
you know,
they got kids and they've got to deal with the whole chemical fucking thing of
that.
They can have postpartum and all of that shit.
You know what I mean?
But as men,
you got no fucking excuse.
They got P90x out there,
they got that rogue fitness,
they got all of this shit out there.
There's no excuse.
As always,
fellas,
we have no excuse.
As always,
you will be held responsible for your actions.
Um,
and that's amazing.
That was an amazing response because I couldn't come up.
I,
if you haven't been listening,
I tried to come up with a response for it and a proper angle and I could not
come up with one.
And uh,
even the lovely Nia came on and she listened to it and she took it personally.
Like I wrote the email to her,
but my wife is cool.
So when I called around her and she laughed,
um,
but it took this person here,
this anonymous person,
look at that.
Not even leaving a name,
didn't want any sort of credit.
What's so fucking ever,
all right ladies response to guy with over way girlfriend.
Okay,
now this is going to be a tough one.
It's going to be a tough one to follow up.
Um,
ladies response to guy with overweight girlfriend.
Hey Bill.
When I was in my mid twenties,
I was dating my longterm boyfriend.
Uh,
I wasn't models skinny when we met,
but we were dining out a lot and I had put on some weight one night.
We had a really honest conversation that served as a wake up call for me.
He was a hundred percent honest and told me he wasn't attracted to me with the
extra weight.
Was it hard?
Harsh?
Yes.
Was it hurtful?
However,
I took our conversation seriously for the first time in my life.
I actually thought about my own health and what I was putting into my,
into my body,
in my body.
Sorry.
I,
if,
if Nia ever said to me,
you've put on weight and I'm not attracted to you.
Like as she was saying it,
I would start putting on my gym clothes.
I'm not saying my bottom lip wouldn't be quivering and there wouldn't be tears
in my eyes,
but I would get my fucking fat,
pasty freckled ass to the nearest God damn elliptical.
Okay.
And I would deal with my feelings later.
I would immediately go right to the solution working out.
Um,
but what we live in a different time now where it's just what you sit there and
you hold somebody's hand right to an early grave.
Okay?
You know,
is the hole too deep that we dug that you're going to die in?
Would you like some fucking Lope,
some bubble wrap down in the bottom when you face plant from a major fucking
heart attack?
Uh,
we started working out together and eating better together.
We both got in better shape when,
when look at dad,
because of his honesty,
I realized how important being healthy is.
Not,
not to mention it's not fair to the fucking person you're with male or female to
to let yourself go.
Yeah,
okay.
I'm not going to be 100% horse because I know there's a bunch of emotional
reasons that people start eating.
So get into therapy,
figure that out and get your ass to the gym and take control of your fucking
life.
The problem with today's,
Oh my God,
I am the old man today.
Oh,
don't tell you what else the problem is.
Yeah.
The,
the fucking Photoshop has to be me sitting on my front porch.
Um,
the problem with all this fucking understanding is you're now,
we've gone from going,
hey tubby,
why don't you lay off the cupcakes to like calling the person brave for eating
cupcakes.
And I think there has to be an adjustment.
Yeah.
Somewhere in the middle of like,
even like that.
Me Too.
Shit.
Like this whole fucking thing had to happen because no one was listening to
these women's complaints,
right.
So then the fucking cork blows off the bottle and then it becomes due processes
out the window.
The burden of proof is now on the person accused.
They have to somehow clear their name,
where the person who accuses them doesn't have to have any evidence.
They just need now you just need to adjust it back.
Where now we're going to listen to women and there's going to be due process
that the safest way to fucking do this shit,
right.
Adjusted back.
The same thing was fat people.
You can't just fucking guy your tablet shit.
They Lard Ass fucking uh,
you know,
go eat a salad.
You fucking fat cunt.
You can't do that.
But to go the entire other way and just say they're brave and they should be
proud of their body and start making fucking,
you know,
car covers into fucking sweatpants,
I don't think is another guy is a good way to date.
You're not helping them that way either.
Um,
okay.
All right.
So this is great.
So he had this painful fucking conversation and she turned this hurt and do a
positive and now I would think that they're in shape banging each other anyways
because of his honesty.
I realized how important it is to be healthy.
I started reading more about diet and FIS fitness,
listening to fitness podcast,
cooking healthy meals,
and continued to work out.
Educating myself and taking the time to care for myself has an all capital
letters changed my life.
I ended up losing 50 pounds and keeping it off all because he had the courage to
tell me his truth.
Ugh.
Ah,
okay.
I loved everything until you use that expression.
He's living his,
I'm living my truth.
Um Oh.
Because he said what the fuck was on his mind.
Okay.
Anyways,
any and she said,
and I wasn't too sensitive to be able to see my shortcomings and improve on
them.
You know,
something I wish I could send this to anybody trying to get over a fucking
problem that's been confronted.
You should have this fucking,
you know,
stitched into a pillow,
old fashioned needle point or something like this.
This is what you gotta do.
Okay.
All right.
Because I'll,
I'll,
you know,
the shit that I'm doing right now with my wife,
she fucking came at me basically straight up telling me what a difficult client
I was to live with.
And anybody who listened to me bitching about NFL football after I just watched
my team win a game to go to the Superbowl can only imagine what my wife has to
go through.
Um,
if I'm bitching about that.
Right.
Um,
so I decided that I was going to just turn it around other than being like,
oh,
she,
she'd be using it as well.
What about the stuff you do?
I knew she was right.
So,
I mean,
there's two ways.
When somebody comes at you,
you can be like,
fuck you.
I'm brave and I'm just speaking my truth and eating my,
my dreams,
you know,
whatever the fuck it is you're doing.
Do you realize Americans,
how fucking dumb you sound to the rest of the world when you're saying you're
living your truth.
And I don't mean other first world countries,
so go fuck yourself.
England,
Germany and all,
you can't to a laugh and right now,
I mean how dumb you sound to the rest of the fucking world that's actually
struggling that you're living your truth.
Well,
you know,
kids in fucking country have to sell your clothes together for an extra fucking
hour because you now feel brave for being a fat fuck.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's hilarious.
Um,
anyways,
she goes on to say I'm actually grateful to him because if he hadn't had the
courage to have had that conversation with me,
I'd probably still be eating junk.
Yeah.
He could have been a fucking diabetic,
lost a couple of toes.
I'm not exercising and continuing an unhealthy lifestyle that would cause issues
for me as I age and some days,
yet you have kids and you're going to die sooner.
Um,
in my opinion and sometimes tough love is necessary.
If you have a strong relationship,
you should be able to be 100% open and honest with each other about everything,
including this love to Nia and the baby Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Why don't more women right into this podcast?
Oh that's right.
Cause I'm the house.
Um,
those are all fucking like both of those God damn emails.
What I love about them was they were both sides of the argument.
What the guy had to do and what the woman has to do in that thing.
You know,
and there are also interchangeable.
So if you're a man listening to this and you're actually in the position of the
woman where your,
your wife or girlfriend has come at you with some tough love.
Yeah,
don't be a fucking baby about it.
Ah,
now I'm on my fucking tree stump here.
You know,
I,
I have been unlikable a lot of my fucking podcast.
I think this is probably the most unlikable.
A zip recruiter.
Wait,
I had done,
I already read all this shit.
Oh sorry.
I scrolled up too far.
All right.
10 year challenge and conspiracy stuff.
Okay.
Oh,
okay.
Uh,
oh,
this is some constraint.
You know,
somebody told me a great joke about a conspiracy theorist
set of conspiracy theories dies and goes to heaven,
or at least he's having his interviewed to try to get into heaven and he meets
God.
And God says,
all right,
congratulations sir,
you lived a great life.
You've made it into heaven and is one of your rewards.
I will answer,
you know,
whatever your top question is that you've ever had in life,
he goes off,
thank God.
Uh,
I want to,
I have to know who is it that killed John F.
Kennedy?
Who are the people that killed them?
And he said,
well,
I can answer that easily.
He goes,
it was Leon Lee Harvey Oswald.
It was,
you know,
it was him and he acted alone and the conspiracy theorists goes out.
Jesus,
this goes higher than I thought.
I'm sure.
I'm sure I butchered it.
Anyways,
tenured challenge and conspiracy stuff.
Dare Bill Illuminati a balloon Menotti.
Oh,
Jesus.
I love that.
All right.
What are your thoughts on the 10 year?
Uh,
my thoughts are if you're an adult,
you shouldn't be doing that.
That's just sounds like something a teenager would be doing.
Oh,
I'm such an old grumpy cunt.
Bad for children,
grow up,
get busy with Diane.
Uh,
the social media thing where people post a pic of themselves from 10 years ago
and today to show how much or little they've changed why or did an article about
the shady daily cold data collecting involved with it.
Also,
I'm 23,
so when I started listening to you in 2011,
I was younger and definitely intrigued by the conspiracy stuff,
but never had enough of a perspective on history and everything till now.
Okay.
I let him,
I've read a lot more about that crazy shit.
History is fed.
While I don't believe that the moon is actually an alien base,
I do believe that the official story is often bullshit.
Yeah.
That's called being enlightened.
But for a lot of people they'll still say,
oh,
what are you putting on your tinfoil hat?
Um,
yeah,
the official story is usual.
Usually 90% of the time is bullshit and all you have to do is just look at
yourself as a human being.
Anytime you get in trouble,
anytime there's a controversy,
you know how much you're spending it.
You know,
I've always said,
you know when,
when was,
has a cop ever pulled up to a two car accident and one person says,
that fucking guy came out of nowhere and t boned me and then when he walked up
to the other guy,
the other guy,
the cop goes,
what happened?
And the other guy goes,
man,
I came out of fucking nowhere and t bolt them.
It's always going to be like his version of it and they're both fucking in the
right anyways.
He said,
I think the most frustrating thing is how little people care about declassified
files.
That confirms that was once crazy talk.
Yeah.
Because they view it as this weird way,
their perception,
they view it as this isn't how things have been handled historically and
continue to be handled today.
They view it as well.
All those people who said that shit,
we're dead or dead now.
That stuff happened before I was born.
They for some reason cannot make the leap until up until the modern era.
Like,
uh,
my wife just sent me something where there was a family,
you know,
that was dealing in the business of Oxycontin and how they are being accused.
There's all these emails of them suppressing information about how fucking
addictive that stuff was in.
If that is true,
those people,
you know,
if they don't get the death penalty,
what they've done to people,
what they've done to families and I'm,
you know,
I know like three close personal friends of mine that are,
have dealt with it or a dealing with it and um,
I don't know.
And just all of this shit,
I mean,
come on,
I think and in boy kills me now is now cause corporations own media and all of
this shit,
the same ones who are fucking us over who dictate our foreign policy.
If you criticize anything about that,
then they,
then they just go when they wipe out your fucking career.
Um,
but anyways,
as far as the 10 year challenge,
I mean,
yeah,
there are definitely data collecting data,
I would think.
And they're selling data and then it just gets too,
who are they selling it to and what are they going to use it for?
Like that 10 year challenge stuff.
If you give that to the police,
that could help them find a missing kid.
Okay.
Um,
but then it's also for,
you know,
it's like anything,
if it falls into the wrong fucking hands,
like there's nothing wrong with an ar 15 until a fucking Luna Luna tick gets
one.
There's nothing wrong with guns until some fucking moron gets one.
Um,
so then that becomes the thing that people then debate.
Yeah.
Because there's morons out there should nobody have,
um,
is there a way to control who gets them?
Blah,
blah,
all of that shit.
So,
um,
I dunno.
Well,
welcome to the frustrating world of being,
at least I'm enlightened.
I'm not saying enlightened,
like you're 100% right on everything that you're thinking about,
but to sit there and say that the official story is often bullshit.
Yeah,
it is often bullshit,
right?
From why a team got rid of a player to a why we're fighting a war.
All of it is going to be spun.
Um,
I'll tell you what's hilarious.
When I was overseas,
I kept doing this thing,
say in like a,
in the middle of my act,
I would just be like,
you know what?
Now I'm going to take time out of my Yak to talk about the greatest country in
the world,
the United States of America.
Okay.
And everyone would start laughing and then all,
I wouldn't even do jokes.
I would just start spewing out our propaganda,
beacons of freedom,
defending the rights of Blahblahblah and everybody bursting out laughing like I
was doing stand up comedy and all I was doing was just saying
what my government says to me,
what we're doing.
All right.
I did that in every city,
all seven countries,
and they all laughed.
Okay,
now,
yeah,
you're going to fucking tell me that.
Yeah.
That by doing that as a test because I knew that they were going to laugh,
but I just wanted to see like how hard they were going to laugh.
Um,
how could I just sit there and be like,
well,
what,
what I'm being told is 100% fucking truth.
There has to be in at least another side to this fucking story.
Right.
I Dunno.
Anyways,
plowing ahead here.
Um,
I,
I would personally,
I wouldn't do that.
I wouldn't send my DNA into the Internet to find out what percentage German,
Irish,
French,
whatever the fuck I am.
Um,
I do think the,
you know,
it's fascinating
okay
to figure that out,
but I just don't trust people that have,
you know,
I mean one of the biggest lie,
the brand new,
the new checks in the mail,
they used to be the old lie.
The modern version of that lie is this is a secure site.
None of them are secure and you should be guarding everything that you can.
But at this point,
even with myself,
I just think,
you know,
it's too late.
Like so much shit is out there.
But just because that's too late,
it doesn't mean you can't educate your kids to not do that.
And,
um,
I dunno,
I,
I am amazed with,
you know,
all of blood,
the stalkers that are out there,
especially with women,
that the fact that you can go on the Internet and essentially find anybody and
figure out,
you know,
where they are.
Um,
and also that,
you know,
if you're not paying attention,
like you'll send out a fucking something to one of these social media sites in a
little leaves,
we'll say your location,
where you're at in that moment.
Um,
I,
I don't know,
like how,
how can that end up being a good fucking thing?
All right.
Money free time and seclusion.
Jesus Christ.
I think you're describing my dreams,
my goals,
my life goals,
living my truth,
having money,
free time and seclusion is great.
Hey,
a dear Billy lifestyle.
I'm 37 years,
years old and just started making really good money.
I used to work a shit job for a government contractor.
I spent 12 years working nine to five and two Saturdays a month.
Now I work 15 to 20 hours a week and make three times as much.
Hey,
welcome to the world at dealing drugs.
Uh,
the differences with that,
with all this free time,
I don't feel like being social anymore.
I don't have the same amount of steam to blow off in my free time is almost more
valuable because I know what to do with it.
I'm drinking less and feel great.
My friends think I'm being lame,
but fuck them.
Do you see any problem with any of this?
Am I leading myself down a path to die alone?
If I do die alone,
it'll certainly be peaceful.
All right,
well I'm,
I'm not saying die alone,
but I also did you just becoming an adult?
You know what I mean?
You're becoming like,
uh,
okay.
Yeah.
You don't need to go out and go out and listen to it.
Go out to some fucking bar.
Well,
you have to scream over the god damn music just sitting there getting hammered
or wet or whatever.
Blowing money.
Um,
I think,
uh,
okay.
I don't know.
How can I put this here?
Yeah.
All right.
I don't think you're being lame because you want to,
uh,
because you know,
you don't go out.
That's just,
that's just becoming an adult.
You're,
you're a fucking adult.
That's all it is.
All right.
And,
and by you growing up,
your freaking them out because it's like,
wait a minute,
this is the party over and I'm still at it.
Am I that guy?
Um,
but I,
I would stop short of dying alone.
You need,
what I would do is with your free time rather than go out to bars,
go out and do some sort of activity.
Like I dunno what the softball league or some shit,
I'm old.
I don't know what they,
I mean I'm so old.
Go rollerblading.
Join a roller blade team.
I'm from the 90s.
I don't fucking know.
Go play walleyball I think that sports is finally going to take off,
which was volleyball combined with,
um,
I would do something positive like that short of joining a church group and I
would do that.
And then maybe you'll meet a great woman there who also doesn't need to go out
and fucking do Yeager's shots.
Well into your thirties.
Congratulations.
You finding out what makes you happy.
Uh,
you're working smarter,
you're working smarter.
Speaking of working smarter,
we,
I have a big announcement that's coming out tomorrow on Tuesday.
I'm not allowed to say it,
but its announcement about a certain project.
Um,
so check in on my social media sites.
If you have the time,
if you don't,
I understand and I'll just bring it up on Thursday and I'll tell you anyways.
All right.
Thinking about breaking up with my girlfriend.
Oh,
Gj age.
Okay.
Hey Billy.
Big Time.
Uh,
as the title suggests,
I'm thinking about breaking up with my girlfriend.
We've been going out for three ish years,
minus a break in the middle.
I broke up with the last summer,
but like a moron,
I got back together with her a month later after failed prospects.
Oh boy.
That is not a reason to get back together with her.
And you're already saying like a moron.
Yeah.
You,
yeah.
Okay.
She's what I would call wife material responsible.
Good looking can cook,
caring.
You know,
my only problem is we don't have sex.
Don't get me wrong.
We get physical,
but it usually ends in either a,
yeah,
a hi or nothing.
H I,
yeah,
parentheses.
Same thing for her because it's all she lets me do,
I can't read that word that's written on my,
I need glasses here.
I don't know.
I was at some new young slang,
a high h I don't get me wrong.
We get physical.
I can feel all that.
You guys laughing at me that I don't know what this means.
We get physical,
but I use,
but it usually ends in either a high or nothing.
She just says hello.
Same thing for her because it's all she lets me do.
She's Catholic enough for it to be annoying and falls back on it.
When we talk about controversial shit,
I try to have a productive conversation.
She sandbags with excuses.
Dude,
I don't know what you're talking about here.
Is She a virgin?
Anyways?
I don't have a problem that she's Catholic.
It's just gets irritating.
When she pulls out their religious propaganda.
I'm not religious,
but I'm also not a Douche bag atheists.
I just don't give a shit.
I need help here,
Bill,
you need help.
Explain.
What is the fuck I don't get what's going on.
You're saying,
oh,
you don't have sex at all.
I thought you meant by we don't have sex as we barely have sex anymore.
So you're saying we don't have sex at all.
She's,
she's cat because she's Catholic.
Uh,
I,
okay.
Um,
I need help here,
Bill.
It was fun while it lasted,
but I feel like I'm wasting my time now.
To me,
sex is a whole other side of her relationship to her.
It isn't.
That's fine.
We're different in this fact.
If I break up with her,
I'm not going back not doing that.
That shit again.
By the way,
we're both 21 and I haven't had sex yet.
Not By choice and neither is she.
Oh,
all right.
A ps.
I know it's late,
but I fucking love your show at the Altria killed his usual.
I drug my family along.
I think it would say I drug my family.
Forgot where the theater was,
even though I occasionally work security for the acts there,
Miss Dinner,
and almost missed the show according to them.
A 15 minutes early is fucking perfect for me.
Uh,
they forgot all about it after the show.
If you want more details about my problem,
let me know.
All right.
See you both 21.
Um,
all right,
dude,
I'm just going to go back to what that woman's advice was.
All right.
You can't change people.
I would want to pressure somebody into doing something,
especially sexually,
that they didn't want to fucking do.
So either you accept that this is what she wants to do.
Are you fucking walk?
I mean,
that's it.
Um,
you said the big thing that sticks with me,
she said I broke up with their last summer,
but like a moron,
I got back together with her a month later after failed prospects.
So it seems to me you think it was dumb to get back with her and that a month
later because you know,
you weren't banging somebody.
You got scared that you're going to be all alone.
Uh,
I think you both want to different things.
Okay.
All right.
And,
uh,
this is a major thing and if that's how she wants to live her life,
you have to respect it.
And if you want to go out and go bang somebody,
you should go out and go bang them.
So I would say go out and do what's gonna make you happy.
Um,
and that's it.
And when you break up with their,
don't fucking get back together with her.
Unless you're going to be able to deal with the fact that she's never going to
bang you until you are just merrier.
But a ring on it,
man,
put a ring
and then fucker put a ring on it.
Don't have any shit fucker.
Then divorced her.
That's the worst comment ever.
Don't do that.
All right.
That's it.
That's brand new.
Hybrid.
The crabby old man on this podcast.
Okay.
I remember football and it was fun.
Um,
that's it.
I stand by my fire.
Would love to hear you guys fucking opinions.
You guys can call me a fucking old man or whatever.
I would love to have your opinions on is anybody else old like me?
And you just remembered like a,
you know,
defense was fucking allowed.
I don't know.
I have no idea.
Uh,
anyways,
that's it.
That's a podcast.
Go fuck yourselves.
And I'll check in on you on Thursday.
Hey,
look for my announcement tomorrow.
Bye.